hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to cuphead okay so this
is the end of it I think I'm not I
wasn't sure one hell of a time in dd-do
it is indeedy-do it is well well well
look how far you've come
not only did you bust up my
good-for-nothing Lackey king dice but I
see you've got my soul contracts as a
greeter and am over and join my team
[Music]
welching on me just like all the others
eh I'll teach you for backing out of a
deal how about you alright fine then
whatever how about you sir mister devil
if that is your name oh this is probably
gonna be tough as hell I get it oh oh
that's whoa I didn't know that hurt -
okay whoa oh boy this is gonna be a
doozy oh boy oh boy the animation team
really went to town on this one Oh
Nellie Wyllie
okay well II Nellie alright that's not
good oh yeah not even close not even
close
alright here we go miss Becky
oh we're here oh wow spaghetti spaghetti
junction oh that's a new one I've got
the slapper you can't defeat my out you
can total eight the fade my slap I'm
sorry it's absolutely absolutely you can
you can 100% defeat slapper
boink oh you can't even touch the arms
well that's gonna be that's gonna be a
tit sprinkle
oh [ __ ] what was I doing I wasn't here I
was just spacing out there you like
taking in the scenery like I was just I
was literally just looking at everything
else being like man this is really
pretty all this is really well animated
it's just gotta admit the detail in the
background and hell is like well that's
new okay I don't like this Oh nope like
that not oh boy yep like that a whole
lot of not holy [ __ ] I don't like that
all right let's see what this will do by
nothing whole lot of nothing these it
gives me an opportunity to hit them with
it that's awfully nice of him oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] boy oh that's not good hate that go
well alrighty then I'll go I guess oh
that's not good oh that's okay ah really
really really really really really
really really oh really Wow
oh boy okay I get this really uh Frick
feel like that's my only commentary to
say this particular encounters really
really really really oh really that hit
me oh yeah sure
okay I believe you
[Music]
well that that definitely got me that
really got me okay that that one really
that one really with me there's gonna be
a doozy
okay sorry I'm not saying anything
because I'm just concentrating so hard
on this okay well you know I'm gonna go
Oh what that hurt me really standing
there when he did that hurt me really oh
boy well you know what you are a second
you are a piece of work young man you
are a real piece of work
whoa way I don't like that that's a bomb
Oh slappa slappa bomb slap a batterer
bomb slap a bomb bat oh boy I panicked
and I'd totally of my own volition
totally those is just me just me nothing
happened I was just scared ah banca
Wonka Danka oh [ __ ] okay okay phase to
phase 2 don't get in the way of the
skeleton when he goes down stay here in
hell oh boy that's QE whoa okay kill
that bomb bat right away that's the
answer to that question oh that
conundrum whoa he's very mad they're
always grumpy Gus I don't know what
that's all about that's that's peculiar
well I'm dead so it doesn't really
matter what it is hey but I'm getting
close I guess but still feels very far
very far back close but very far whoa
whoa I've forgotten how to parry slap
whoa I completely forgot how to pair us
up oh okay all right well here with
phase 2 @ 3l so that's a good thing that
I enjoy ah oh [ __ ] I wasn't even paying
attention that was completely stupid
ah [ __ ] again oh no oh no oh no oh boy I
really boned my whole lead there that
was just ridiculously stupid of me
oh boy oh well alright then
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy what is that
all about what is that all about I don't
like that I don't like that I don't like
that I don't like that I don't like that
I don't like that I know I'm not saving
my super I should save my super in the
second phase in this phase it's good
because it helps me the the little
[ __ ] if they walk in the corners it
can help alleviate that but for the
other one I should definitely save my
super for when it's okay well I should
save my super for when it's really
necessary because when he's a big head
he I'm definitely gonna be able to hit
him I should definitely save it for that
phase if anything here definitely just
shield up because it's like an extra
buffer like there he was in the corner
and if I hadn't had that it would have
been bad for me okay here we go here we
go here we go phase two phase do phase
two I'm gone I'm gone I'm gone okay so
this is where I got to save up my super
I can't I can't spend it on the
stupidity of the other one I'm watching
you baby there we go there we go there
we go there we go there we go there we
go there we go there we go there we go
there we go oh no where you going
ooh that's a big boy super ready
oh [ __ ] wasn't paying attention but I
got it anyway I'm getting it Oh full
damage full damage I didn't get the
other parry slap but that's okay
yah yah yah yah yah yah I said I should
have saved it for this phase but I guess
I didn't do that might have forgotten
all about it
[Music]
whoa how did that damage I will never
know I will never ever there we go
that's my end is my end this is Maya ah
[ __ ] ticks
oh man that one is hard if I need to
save the super for that phase because I
can't be in there long I I if I had the
super then I would have cut that phase
down and I wouldn't have been subjected
to the horrors that I experienced Oh No
oh no oh no that's you know I can't if I
don't go into the next phase with full
health I'm dead I mean I'll try if I get
close but oh wow okay this is oh boy
going into phase 2 with one health
that's kind of the opposite of what I
was hoping for oh well here we go I got
this super waiting for me which is
awfully nice [ __ ] what's scary there
we go
alright it's gonna get here gonna use
this I've only got one health
oh [ __ ] almost lost it oh oh oh jeez
that guy died Wow okay I didn't even
know they could die like that oh wow
okay Oh No how close was I not as close
as I could be to get angry if I hadn't
lost the health in the first round to
health in the first round which was
stupid is like Easy Street
this shouldn't cause any trouble oh you
know what I realized what what gun might
be better is the spread shot I'm not try
to change weapons good god oof I've
almost got this I'm very close to
getting it I just need to I I don't
think the charged shot is the right
ability I think the spread shot either
batter yeah that or the lobber would be
good let me try the lobber oh I got this
alright come on
no no [ __ ] well I can't parry for craps
so it doesn't change anything I don't
know if the lava is gonna be the best
one that seems like a unfortunately
weird one
[Music]
[ __ ] all right
that's definitely not not good and I'm
gonna go back I'm gonna get the e spread
ah there you go how do you like that
spread in your face huh hey you like it
devil baby you like it you like it you
like it
Oh bet you like it oh you love it oh you
love it
oh [ __ ] oh how did I dodge that I don't
know something tells me the spreads on
my whelks Cod Tim I just had to open my
big flip flap in flapjack er didn't I
I just had the yap on about how oh this
is the one this is the good stuff
there's really give him him go watch fur
hey how's it going there all right well
there he is okay there I go all right
whoo all right to health not bad if I
can get through this next part okay cuz
this is this really where it makes a
difference cuz it's just me whaling on
him like non-stop right well what whoa
whoa what the hell whoa I forgot dip
down right bumper to make Manton me
stick holy [ __ ] that was so stupid of me
oh god that was stupid okay I got my
super I know I'm just waiting for the
next next one here we go
okay whoa
oh oh oh oh he's crying whoa whoa miss
that one
why are you crying buddy Oh spread was
the key spread was the key spread was
the key holy [ __ ] Oh Nellie one health
left Wow
wowie Zowie wowie Zowie Wow
a mine is not bad not bad at all just
about 30 minutes on that fight the
brothers had triumphed over the demon
forcing him to finally give up we shall
accept your surrender devil cop had
laughed but we're not done just yet
and with that cup head mug man destroyed
all the soul contracts releasing inkwell
Isles residents from eternal servitude
to the devil gosh I can't wait to tell
everybody Cup had said the boys set off
for home and at top speed
come on is little last one there's a
leaky Cup mug man teased to say ran once
on the brothers gathers everyone
together you're all free of the devil's
depth Cup had announced and that fiend
won't bother us ever again bug man
Abaddon the elder kettle was literally
brimming with pride as everyone began to
cheer even the [ __ ] out of all of us as
an all-day celebration began the
brothers promise to never wander into
trouble again
and they didn't until the next time of
course but that is another story oh that
was beautiful oh those beautiful I love
that so much God the passion that went
into that game oh I can't say anything
that hasn't already been said about this
game but that was absolutely wonderful
our sincere appreciation to the members
of our team who loyally and creative
endeavor made this possible production
Chad and Jared moldenhauer you guys are
awesome and you guys are awesome for
watching thank you everybody for
sticking with me through this I know I'm
not the best cut bat player babe
I told you I was good at shmups I ain't
the Boris in the world so that was a lot
of fun I loved that it was really really
cool I had a great time playing it from
beginning to end oh man that was so much
fun I can't imagine the amount of work
that went into each and every frame of
that because all that was hand hand
drawn hand animated turning a game into
an experience that was beyond anything
that I've ever seen before
totally unique completely original and a
challenge and just an all-around blast
so thank you everybody somebody for
watching I'm gonna stick around to the
end of the credits just to see if
there's anything at the end of that I
hope for a sequel to this game support
the release if you like this game and
you haven't bought it yet buy it because
it's such a delightful thing and you
just want to see more stuff like this
forget all the triple-a like yearly
release [ __ ] get more things like
this because like games are developed by
what people buy and if everyone's buying
the triple-a stuff that's great but it's
just all this money put into a sink that
has no passion into it whereas things
like this have so much passion dripping
through every single second of the game
love it love it love it to death a
little bit a million times so I'm gonna
get to the end and then I'm gonna say
goodbye oh they're their own fans
ah they don't answer alright what was
that
Oh what did I miss did I just miss
something all right well anyway that is
cop head thank you again everybody for
watching there was something at the end
there but there will be another video
probably on YouTube that outlines
whatever that was so thank you everybody
so much for watching let's all get a
sequel made and as always I will see you
in the next video bye
[Music]